مرض السكر بيحول العالم بوجه ازمه فدول
كثيره في العالم فيها نقص في ابر معروفه
لعلاج السكري وكثر من المرضى مو قادرين
يلاقوا علاجهم عدم توفره سببه مو ارتفاع
عدد الاصابات بالسكري انما سببه انه في
ناس ثانيه داخله على الخط وبدات تستخدم
العلاج وهذول هم الراغبين في انقاص
اوزانهم الابر اللي بنتكلم عنها اسمها
وزنفل وهذه ابر معتمده لعلاج السكري وفيها
نقص في دول كثيره في العالم وتحديد كمان
حتى في امريكا في هذه الابر في هجوم عليها
من الراغبين في النحافه كنا بتسبب انقاص
الوزن وبالتالي بدا المصابين بالسكري ما
يلاقوا الدواء ومع البحث اكتشفنا شيء ثاني
كمان فالشركه المنتجه لهذه الابر الشهيره
حول العالم ابر ثانيه اسمها ويجوها هذه
الابر مكونها هو نفس مكون
وانما بجرعه اعلى وهذه الابر اصلا ابر
مخصصه لعلاج السم ولا تصرف الا بوصفه طبيب
لكن هذه الابر غاليه وجديده نسبيه فكميه
تصنيعها مو عاليه نسبيه هذا غير مشاكل في
سلاسل الامدادات هذه كلها مشاكل عملت نقص
في توفر وجوفي والنقص وصل لدرجه انه
الشركه بتنشر بيانات عنه على موقعها
وبتوعد الناس بزياده في التصنيع هذه السنه
فهذا الشيء خل الراغبين في انقاص اوزانهم
ويروحوا لذنبك لانها ببساطه فيها نفس
الماده الفعاله ونفس المفعول اللي بيخلل
الوزن وانما بجرعه اقل امام هذه الازمه
مرض السكري يا اما مضطرين ياخذوا جرعات
اقل من الموصوفه لهم او جالسين بيحولوا
الابر اخرى ما لها نفس الفعاليه عموما
الموضوع اذا بيثير اسئله كثير جدا عن علاج
السمنه بالابر ومين اللي المفروض ياخذ هذه
الابر وكاف وهل هذه الابر تحديد ان الناس
جالسه بتاخذها لها اعراض جانبيه مثلا ولا
هي فعلا علاج
للوزن الزائد خلينا نحاول نفهم هذا
الموضوع وكل ما يخصه من مختص فمعنى من
الخبر دكتور وليد البكر استشاري السكري
والغدد الصماء اهلا فيك معنا دكتور وليد
همم خليني في البدايه بس اسالك كيف صار
هذا التحول انه من ابر بتستخدم في علاج
السكري صار فيك اكتشاف انه الموضوع برده
له علاقه بالسمنه
مساء الخير عليكم
في تنزيل
اوكي شركات المصنعه تصنع منها مكونات
تساعد في تنزيل الوزن وتسوق كعلاج الوزن
طبعا الاذن وهناك ايضا
ادويه اخرى همم
هي عباره عن السكر اااه دول بكلوزه تطور
الى نسمه وحده
للوزن ومعتمه الدوليه للوزن اما الاوزمبك
فهو طبعا الان حاليا الدواء معتمد للسكر
وطور منه الى ان يصبح دواء اسمه وجوبي
اللي موجود الان في امريكا
كعلاج للسمنه فهذه حقيقه تتقاطع مع علاج
السكر بانه لها فنيه
بازال الوزن همم
اكثر على مرضى السكر انه نقصهم العلاج
بنسبه كبيره كونه السنهيه الان منتشره في
المملكه وفي العالم بشكل وهذا اللي يزاد
الطلب عليها بشكل كبير جدا
دكتور الفتره الاخيره انا ما بسال احد
بقول له انت كيف نحفت اللي بيقول لي
اوزمبك اخذت ابر اوزمبك طيب همم يعني هذا
المفروض علاج لمرض محدد يعني
ايش نقدر نقول لما بياخذوه الناس اللي هم
بس عندهم مشكله عاديه في الوزن انه ساعات
هي بس كم كيلو بدهم ينزلوها ايش ممكن يكون
بيصير لهم
همم
ولكن احيانا عندما تفشل الحميه والرياضه
ويكون الوزن في معدلات العاليه بمعنى لو
كتله الجسم تكون اعلى من 30
شخص كتب الجسم تبعه اكثر من 27 معه موجود
قابلين الثقه او الكسره فهنا تنطبق عليه
استخدام الوزن ولا يفضل استخدام العشوائي
الي يحصل الاسد باخذ عشوائيا بدون همم
وبدون تحاليل وهدوم متابعه دقيقه على
المدى الطويل
طيب يعني ايه هذه الفكره الاساسيه انه كل
شيء لازم يكون مع طبيب لازم كل شيء يكون
فيه مراجعه كل هذا الكلام طيب الناس نحنا
عارفين بيروحوا بيجيبوا بيشتروا وبيدوا
نفسهم الابره مره في الاسبوع
قليله جدا
قد تحصل التهابات في البنكرياس وهذه نادره
همم احيانا تؤثر على نفسيه الشخص او تزيد
الاكتئاب احيانا ولهذا هناك اشياء معينه
الطبيعي يتاكد الا توجد هناك مواضع من
استخدامها وايضا المريض على ذلك همم قبل
ان تحصل المضاعفات احيانا باستخدامها
دكتور وليد لو انا جيتك قلت لك والله
دكتور وليد عندي ثلاثه كيلو ابغى انزلهم
لو عملت لي الفحوصات ولقيت كل شيء انه
تمام عادي تعطيني
هي الاساس طبعا هنا يعني هذه ال ال كميه
الكيلوات الزائده قليله جدا فم حقيقه ما
تصل مرحله انك تاخذ الابر وتعرض نفسك
لمضاعفات الابر من ناحيه الغثيان والتعب
او قد
روحي فاذا كانت نسبه وزن بسيطه
اما اذا كانت نسبه عاليه وفشل الانسان
بالرياض الحميه هنا يكون في ممكن نستخدمها
لها بعدها ثقيل طبعا اوكي اذن بالمبدا
يعني فعلا ممكن اللجوء لها كعلاج ولكن يجب
مراجعه الطبيب اولا وطبعا لازم يكون فعلا
فيه وزن زائد ان احنا بنتكلم كثير بس انت
الاعراض اللي بتتكلم عنا الدكتور كمان في
نفس الوقت بعض الناس ممكن يقول لك طب ما
اتحملها عادي عادي امشيها اسبوعين وننزل
كم كيلو واخلص يعني
في في هناك بعض الاشياء المهمه انا طبعا
بنعالج السمنه او زياده الوزن او البدانه
نعالجك كمشكله صحيه ليست مشكله جماليه
بمعنى احيانا الوزن اذا زاد باثر على
الركب الانسان على ظهره فعلا على ايضا
دهون الكبد على قابليه
الداخليه
اذا كان المنفعه عاليه من نزول الوزن على
مستوى الصحه والنفسي
والميكانيكي في الجسم
الواحد تتحسن نفسيته لما ينحف شكله احلى
ههه هذه تاخذها بعين الاعتبار ممكن
المشكله ان الوزن الان مطلب جمال ايضا
يعني راح على كل الاجناس وهذا طبعا يجعل
هناك طلب كبير وهذا يجعل النقص الكبير
والطلب العالي على ان في بعض الناس ما
وصلوا لمرحله يعني احتياج الابره ولكن
ياخذونها من اجل المطلب الوزن مثالي
كثير صراحه انا اعرفهم دكتور يعني فعليا
بيلجاوا الان لهذه الابره بس السؤال هو
كمان اللي بيطرح نفسه اذا هو هذا علاج
محدد لمرضى السكري وان تذكرت انه يعني في
ادويه او ابر ثانيه تستخدم للسمنه وما الى
ذلك كيف هذا
النوع من الادويه
بتنباع او بتنصرف من غير وصفات طبيه يعني
عادي
للان طبعا وزاره الصحه السعوديه طبعا صرف
الاوزن لك هو بيكون وصفه طبيه
الناس الي عندهم سكر في المملكه وطبعا
احنا عارفين لا نصها
بتنصرف من غير وصفات الناس ما شاء الله
صاروا بيبعثوها لبعض حول العالم
المملكه
انه صح ينحفك ولكنك مضطر انك تاخذ هذه
الابره مدى الحياه علشان مستويات السكر في
الجسم وما الى ذلك هل هذا الكلام صحيح
طبعا السمنه هي مرض مزمن تبقى مع الانسان
دائما انه عاملها زي معامله السكر والضغط
انا بتكلم عن الناس اللي صراحه بياخذوها
عشان كم كيلو
الا اذا كان السمنه في حدود الرقم العالي
اللي يسبب اثر ميكانيكي وصحي على الجسم
شهر هل لازم بعد الشهر يستمروا ياخذوها
واللي عادي يوقفوها وما راح يصير شيء
طبعا هذا استخدام يعني انا ما اوصي فيه
ابدا انزل وزن طبيعي
نحنا بنشكرك على هذه التوضيحات هذه
المداخله كان معنا من الخبر دكتور وليد
البكر استشاري السكري والغدد الصماء شكرا
لك دكتور
[موسيقى]